an image filter is something that takes
an image proaches it in some way and
outputs an image in response so last
time we talked about kernel convolution
and I did Gaussian blur and mean blur a
couple of examples of a sort of thing
you can convolve over an image today
we're going to talk a little bit about a
different type of kernel convolution
that is the edge detection the process
we'll be using in this video is still
kernel convolution like we used in the
last video so if you haven't seen that
video you might want to go back just to
sort of make sure you absolutely know
what's going on edge detection is is
simply a case of trying to find the
regions in an image where we have a
sharp change in intensity or a sharp
change in color a high value indicates a
steep change and a low value indicates a
shallow change a very common operator
for doing this is a Sobel operator what
it is is an approximation to a
derivative of an image so there's it's
separate in the Y and the X directions
so if we look at the X direction then
the gradient of an image in the X
Direction is equal to this operator here
this is our kernel 3x3 which is nice and
small so it's quite quick so we have
minus numbers on the left hand side and
positive numbers on the right hand side
and we're sort of preserving a little
bit the center pixels because we've got
these two values here which is slightly
higher weighted for these ones so what
we're doing here essentially is trying
to find out the amount of difference
between this region of our image and
this region of our image here by simply
taking one away from the other so we'll
pass this just like before we'll pass
this over every pixel of our image and
it will give us a response for this
location here bearing in mind the pixels
around it so because you've got 0 down
the middle it's not going to do anything
up and down it's just looking yet to see
if there is a if you like a vertical
line with that view yeah this is
symmetrical if vertically okay so it's
not going to do anything to do with
edges but orientated horizontally in the
image so if you've got a bit of image
say but looks a bit like this let's draw
a bit of image these are my pixels they
were not all the same size in the last
video we used an image that had 50 in
these values and 100 over here so it was
an edge right if this is our image right
here is an edge fairly obviously we can
see that but a computer card so if we
put our Sobel operator here then what we
essentially doing is doing 100 times 1
plus 100 times 2 plus 100
1 plus 55 minus 1 plus 50 times minus 2
plus 50 times minus 1 and get gives us
an output of 200 which is reasonable
okay and you can imagine if all of these
values are the same so if they were all
50 throughout then you just get 0 so
this will provide a big response where
one side is bright or dark of any other
side and yes it's orientated right -
left or left - right but we'll get rid
of that later a bit the actual direction
and we'll just so the if you like the
sign of the output it doesn't matter no
for this it doesn't ok now this is only
half the battle right so we've only
calculated the x-direction we want to
calculate the Y direction
you know people already managed to guess
what the kernel for this is so G of Y
okay and it's minus 1 minus 2 minus 1 1
- 1 0 its 0 there we go ok so exactly
the same but you have alternation okay
so this will produce a response of 0 on
this edge because this row is the same
as this row so big inner cancel each
other out in normal photographs this is
never going to come up there's going to
be something going on right so it's
that's interesting which direction it is
we don't know the output of either of
these filters individually could be
negative if one side is much bigger than
the other okay so what we're going to
get if we put tourney's into an image
let's imagine we stretch those negative
and positive values to between naught
and 255 and just output it into a
grayscale image then what we'll have is
an image that's mostly gray with black
on one side of each edge and white on
the other side depending on the
orientation of the edge and the same for
the Y but what we really want to do is
take both of those values and turn them
into one how big is this edge so when
you say about the black and the white
that's because you get in a plus and a
minus
yes yes so if you take if you take let's
say a value of minus one to plus one and
you scale it from naught to 255 and all
the - values are going to be the blacks
and all the positive values of any bid
the whites up above 128 so at the moment
what we have is a set of values that
represents how strong our gradient is
vertically in how strong it is
horizontally and what we really want is
the total of those things ok so just
like with a standard kind of hypotenuse
of a triangle we can basically square
both these values add them together and
square root it and that will give you
the general magnitude so I'll write that
down and then
remove more sending so we've got a value
of a gradient in the X direction and
we've got a value of the gradient in the
Y direction and the total gradient the
magnitude of a gradient is given by the
square root of g x squared plus g y
squared ok you'll see but what this does
by squaring and n square root N and we
also remove a sign have you got an eye
on a spot on numberphile is this is this
why we're doing equation though what
don't put me on there because my mass is
it looks good at but it falls down quick
so you can see is from if we're squaring
them and square rooting them then that
removes the sign so this magnitude is
now positive all the time ok and a value
of 0 will be an absolutely consistent
color so this is this is a function to
get rid of the sign and show the time
yeah and now if the gradient in the X
Direction is big but the gradient in the
Y Direction is small you'll get two
moderately large gradient if the
gradient both directions is big you'll
get a pretty large gradient and so it
will basically be how big is the edge at
this location ok and it will be a black
and white image if we scale it up
another interesting thing is because we
know the signed gradient in the X and
the y directions we can calculate the
angle of the of the edge as well so the
orientation of the edge is given by
inverse tan arc tan of Gy over G X so
essentially if you take the gradient
result from your G Y and a great result
from Y of GX you divide them and then
you calculate the inverse tan of that it
will give you a value in radians or
degrees that says what orientation in
the image is that particular pixel and
that can be really useful for finding
structures or finding objects and things
like that it's unusual for Sobel if ever
to be run on color ok this is a
grayscale operator so obviously you'll
need to convert your image if it's in
color to grayscale first so that we're
talking just about changing intensity
also Sobel is very very it's not what
could you run it on color out of
interest you could will it give you a
wacky output it would get well you'd
have three values of edge detection for
the different color channels on what
entire short that would mean so but yes
you're suppose you could I don't tend to
so the other thing is that so Bill's
very it's been
be noisy okay we're using a small kernel
and images change a lot so you're going
to see a lot of edges where it's not
actually really an edge in our sense of
the word another thing would be if you
had a camera with a fairly high ISO
settings you had a lot of grainy noise
that's going to produce a sort of
low-level edge over everything which is
not all we want so it's very common to
use a Gaussian blur first over soberly
before so we'll edge detector just to
get rid of the low the high-frequency
stuff and keep the low frequency big
walls that we're looking for you would
do color to grayscale conversion then
you would use a Gaussian filter to blow
it a small one not too big and then you
would use a Sobel edge detector and that
will produce your nice black and white
image where big white bright edges and
dark everything else
written some quite cool code which has
got loads of comments in so everyone who
even if you don't code you should better
follow it along there'll be people who
complain this in c-sharp I don't care
about those people okay if you want we
can record a nice why I see sharp rocks
rant and you can provide no mushy